un mâle charrier bonjour c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup d'allées et venues
inde allers-retours dans l'est dans la
rhétorique dans les sorties une jean
yves le drian qui évoque ce matin une
situation très grave à quel point
faut-il s'inquiéter aujourd'hui les dix
prochains jours lors des manoeuvres
russe là vont être effectivement
compliqué à suivre parce que vladimir
poutine y c'est que tout le monde les
observe et tout le monde vient lui
parler tout le monde bien à lui donc il
en profite aussi pour quelque part aller
en plus énervé ces manoeuvres elles sont
habituelles en vélo aussi donc sur la
manoeuvre en elle même on peut pas
s'étonner par contre ce qui est plus
étonnant c'est le nombre de soldats
russes qui sont envoyées habituellement
on est sur 300 là on est passé sur 38
donc il ya une telle différentiel que
forcément ça veut dire que ce sont des
manoeuvres d'une autre ampleur puis si
on regarde la carte à partir du moment
donné où vous avez plus de banales et
derrière plus de monde ça veut dire que
forcément ça va plus loin et donc
forcément ça va vers la frontière
polonaise et surtout vers la frontière
ukrainienne donc comme on est toujours
dans des manoeuvres théoriquement
l'admirent poutine dit ça ne vous
regarde pas ce qu'on y fait mais si on
regarde avec une capacité de prise en
tenaille de l'ukraine on voit bien que
entre ce qui se passe d'un côté en
ukraine et du côté de la biélorussie
forcément il ya des risques en plus ces
manoeuvres elles sont à la fois au sol à
la fois avec des moyens aériens ce qui
est un peu neuf à la fois avec des
parachutistes je vous dis comme tout le
monde observe en ce moment on a vu à peu
près qu'elles étaient le contingent
russe qui étaient déployés donc
forcément ça fait monter une pression
supplémentaire par rapport à une
capacité de franchir une frontière
pourquoi le président loukachenko les
styles faire les ruses finalement
aujourd'hui alors pour le président
lukashenko c'est vrai que il y à un
binôme totale avec les russes et ce
binôme il est un peu intéressant si on
regarde et qu'on se rappelle qu'en 2014
quand la russie vient en ukraine et
qu'elle s'empare de la crim est alors
tout à fait légalement 10 des russes par
un vote je vous le rappelle est un
référendum sur place annexion du tour
nous du côté effectivement de l'occident
on se retrouve qu'un président
loukachenko qui le dit pas un mot pas un
commentaire elizabeth pourquoi parce
qu'il sait très bien que ce qui se passe
en ukraine peut tout à fait arrivée en
biélorussie et qu'il n'a pas envie que
les russes qu'il connaît très bien
puisqu'il les a côtoyés touche donc en
plus il ya une tradition de l' empire
soviétique sur son territoire viana
prendre un morceau de la biélorussie
mais entre-temps 2020 lukashenko
élections contestées il ya un seul homme
qui se dresse derrière lui et qu'il
protège il s'appelle bladimir poutine
donc depuis okacha une cour où
travaillent main dans la main avec
vladimir poutine y compris sur ces
questions d'intimidation y compris
disent les américains avec un point
d'interrogation sur une possibilité
question au sidaction vers la vers
l'ukraine merci beaucoup à l'achat
évidemment continuera à scruter
attentivement ce qu'il se passe